Thomas Jefferson, one of America's founding
fathers, came up with the first swiveling
mechanism for office chairs.
Decades later, Charles Darwin added small
wheels called casters to his chair to roll it
around the study as he worked on the theory
of evolution.
Today, office chairs still swivel and roll.
The office chair has become a status symbol.
Executive versions have kingly dimensions.
They're extremely plush and have serious
lumbar support.
Using a hydraulically powered machine, a
worker bends 14 gauge steel tubing to form
the bottom cushion frame.
He joins the ends and welds steel bars to
the middle.
The bars will support the mechanism for
adjusting the position of the seat.
He hooks S-shaped steel springs from the
front to the back of the seat frame.
These sinuous springs will eventually
provide a flexible web of suspension in the
seat. He positions the rods laterally and
clips them to the springs for additional
stability and support.
The office chair seat frame is now complete.
Next, a worker builds the chairs back frame.
The frame includes a spine, lumbar support,
armrest, attachments and other parts.
He grinds burrs and other rough spots from
the steel.
In the upholstery department.
Another worker smooths a leather hide so
that it sits evenly on the cutting table.
He cuts out the patterns following cardboard
templates as he cuts.
He works around the natural flaws in the
hide, making calculated decisions to minimize
waste. By cutting carefully, he'll be able
to get all the leather he needs for one chair
from this large hide.
That's important because color and grain can
vary from hide to hide.
Using pieces from the same one will give the
chair a consistent look and texture.
Once all the leather pattern pieces have
been accumulated, another worker cuts foam
cushioning for backing.
The density of the foam in the chair varies.
He uses more rigid foam for the chairs,
contoured cushioning, so it will hold its
shape. Another worker selects softer foam
for the part of the chair that the occupant's
back will rest against.
He cut slits into the softer back padding.
This creates channels that will ultimately
become a design feature.
Using chalk, he draws lines onto the
corresponding leather that match up with the
slits in the foam.
A worker aligns the chalk lines in the
leather with the slits and puckers the
leather as he sews the backing to it.
This forms a rib pattern in the upper half
of the chair.
Upholstery. He stitches the padding flat to
many of the other pattern pieces.
This particular part is a side panel for the
back of the chair.
Returning to the upholstery with the
ribbing.
Now he sews contoured casings to each side.
To complete the back of the chair.
Workers at a chipboard panel and encase the
structure with foam, then cover it with a
leather upholstery.
Once the chair seat has been upholstered, an
employee installs a plastic cover to enclose
the back. He screws a sliding plate to the
base.
This mechanism will work in conjunction with
the plate to slide the seat forward and
backward, depending on legroom needs.
It also has features for adjusting the tilt
and height of the seat.
The hydraulic cylinder for adjusting the
seat height is next.
The cylinder also doubles as the chair stem
and it swivels to allow the seat to rotate
360 degrees.
He attaches the aluminum base to the
cylinder.
He snaps the casters into slots in the
aluminum base.
He equips the back of the office chair with
an automobile style headrest.
The prongs fit into the brackets in the
chair frame.
Finally, he locks the armrests into the
frame.
This office chair is now ready to make
someone's desk job a lot more comfortable.
Vino brew is just what the name implies.
Vino meaning wine and brew, referring to
beer.
This hybrid beverage is part of a fledgling
trend by some adventurous breweries and
wineries to merge their two otherwise
separate worlds of alcohol and create a
unique drink. This vino brew is made from
port style sweet wine, dark, strong beer
known as stout, and another ingredient
that's brewed coffee.
This concoction is the collaborative
creation of a winery microbrewery and coffee
producer. The microbrewery grows some 20
different varieties of hop plants whose
flowers contain the resins and essential
oils that give beer its bitter and aromatic
characteristics. To begin the beer making
process.
The brewmaster fills a tank called a mash
tun with water, then ignites a burner.
When the water heats to around 150°F, he
pours in a blend of different types of malts.
Malts are cereal grains, such as barley or
corn, which have been soaked to kickstart
germination. Then, once sprouted dried with
hot air to halt germination, stirring the
malt into the hot water activates enzymes
that convert the starches in the grain into
fermentable sugars.
After an hour or so, he transfers just the
liquid called wort to the boil kettle and
gradually adds different varieties of hops.
He brings the water to a boil to kill off
bacteria and sterilize it.
Next, he calls the wart and transfers it to
the fermentation tank.
Then he adds yeast over the next 10 to 14
days.
The yeast consumes the fermentable sugars in
the wort, converting them into alcohol and
producing carbon dioxide gas, which creates
bubbles.
This process transforms the wort into beer.
At the coffee company.
The hot coffee beans must be cooled quickly
after coming out of the roaster so that they
don't overcook.
This perforated cooling pan stirs the beans
to help dissipate the heat.
Then a commercial coffee grinder grinds the
beans into coarse ground coffee.
To prepare coffee for the vino brew.
A worker puts grounds into a filter bag,
saturates the bag with cold water, then
submerges the bag in water, letting the
ground soak for about 16 hours.
Then he pours the coffee into a large jar.
At the winery, Winemakers harvest and press
the grapes, add yeast and ferment them, then
age the port wine for at least two years in
oak barrels to prepare to make vino bru.
The winemakers test samples from different
barrels for acidity and sweetness to help
decide which wines to potentially use.
The winemaker and the coffee maker then
experiment with amounts of those wines and
different cold brew coffees made from
various types of beans.
The brewmaster also joins in measuring out
beer.
This process is as much art as science.
For each batch of vino brew, the respective
makers play with the selection of ingredients
and with the proportions.
Tasting and smelling the samples to evaluate
aroma, sweetness, bitterness and acidity.
What they try to create is a harmonious
blend of the three elements.
A new flavor without the taste of any one
element dominating the others.
Once they pinned down the winning formula,
they replicate it on a large scale for
production. The winery pumps the selected
wine from storage tanks into barrels for
transport to the brewery.
At the brewery, the brewmaster pumps the
required amount of wine from those barrels
into a blending tank.
He pours the required amount of cold brewed
coffee into the blending tank.
Then he pumps the required volume of beer
into the tank.
Beer makes up the largest proportion of the
recipe, followed by wine, then coffee.
After blending the ingredients in the tank,
the brewmaster pumps the brew into a beer
keg. Then he injects carbon dioxide gas to
add more carbonation.
When you pour a glass of vino, bru the
bubbles rise to the top, producing foam known
as beer head. But while this might look and
feel like regular beer, one sip tells you
that vino bru is uniquely different.